let me just ask you what what do you
think makes you guys different i mean
there's just so
many services out there aging bull
really is the best place you can go to
learn about
trading stocks these are actual guys who
are in the markets trading every day
ah yes the beautiful power of hindsight
ladies and gentlemen
we're about to take a look at the
millionaire roadmap miami mastermind
a little ad back in the day because i
want to set up
the whole stage for you because we're
going to get into the gigantic lawsuit
that just came crashing down on raging
bull
but before that let's see what they were
advertising ladies and gentlemen let's
see what they were talking about what
all the buzz was about
raging bull is a couple of uh educators
so-called
educators that are going to teach you
how to trade stocks guys how to trade
penny stocks how to trade options
before you but i can tell you this much
if you don't take that leap
it's not going to happen this is jason
bond he says he's a he's a former
teacher
but he quit all that after he made tons
of money in the stock market got himself
out of debt
and now he's ready to teach you we're
here to support you
just my mentor jeff is the big hefe he
owns most of raging bull and he claims
oh my gosh he's a genius guys
this man has a very high iq he's in
mensa if you don't know what that is
it's it's a whole club
for people who are obsessed with their
iq test scores and his pitch
is that he also can make you wildly
profitable in the stock market ladies
and gentlemen in fact they were pitching
something during covid
and they were saying hey during coven
you can make those pandemic plays
that are going to make you a lot of
money that's what they call them
pandemic place
and we'll get into how that went in a
second but let's let's finish this off
real quick
i taught all of that to kyle he's made
over three million dollars
his top students on the plane we are so
proud of those accomplishments
we are going to make sure that we give
you our best get in the millionaire road
map
i want to see you on this jet with us
next time it's hey
let's get on the jet boys awesome and
you can totally do it you
okay so remember this freeze frame
here the founders of a company called
raging bull
tout themselves as expert stock traders
who teach
customers how they too can become
millionaires
the millionaire roadmap marketing emails
said they found a hidden bull market
in the kovit 19 pandemic
federal regulators aka the federal trade
commission
say the company operators have defrauded
customers
out of more than 137 million dollars
over the past three years and the
coronavirus fueled economic crisis
hasn't tempered their reckless efforts
to duke vulnerable investors
oh my gosh currently they're being sued
uh just came out today the news
holy crap boys this is a big one
and here's the big news right because
these guys all these traders
a lot most of their pitch i mean i would
say 100 of their pitch is reliant on
them
being successful themselves right
because who would buy it from someone
who's not a successful trader so they
all say
i'm such a hot shot i made 250 000
in six months or you know three million
dollars in two years or whatever it is
they all tell you that and they tell you
you can be like me i have a proven
you know path to success but let's look
at the truth
see the federal trade commission did
some dig here's what they say
in one of my favorite sentences from the
lawsuit bishop has incurred and this is
jeff bishop the the genius minsa guy oh
he's so smart
he incurred substantial and persistent
losses as a result of his own stock
and option trading activities he's a
loser
dude bishop's income is primarily
derived from subscription fees consumers
paid a raging bull i mean you know we
know this but to hear the
the popo say it oh it's so gratifying
i just love hearing the federal trade
commission hammering at home
because if i say it guys you know
they're gonna call me libelous they're
gonna try to go after me but you can't
get mad at me i'm just reading off a
lawsuit here
don't get mad at me jason bonds same
thing encourage substantial and
persistent losses guys
you're paying losers to teach you how to
trade stocks
you're paying people who quote incurred
substantial and persistent losses as a
result of his own stock and options
trading activities
in quote this whole idea of joining us
on the jet
you guys can join me on the jet yeah if
you open your own raging bull.com and
sell subscriptions
that's where the real money is in stock
trading it's in selling how to trade
stocks
sorry it's the truth and you're gonna
learn it if you have to go through a
course
and learn it or you can learn it the
easy way and just you know hear what i'm
saying
look at the pattern of behavior look at
history this is where most of these guys
who are not on wall street who are
unregistered who are trying to sell you
financial advice
this is where they're making their money
with the jet ads you know with the hyper
polish
oh i want to make you money i want to
see you on this jet with us next time
i want to see you on the jet
loser just is what it is guys
it's my opinion but here's the crazy
thing okay
before this came out you couldn't find
hardly anything negative about these
guys
why because their endorsements were so
huge all the big people talking about
them
we're all saying glowing reviews but i
don't know if you know this but uh
jordan belfort you know the sales guy
the guy who actually got convicted of
fraud for stock stuff
yeah actually he launched a product with
them after getting out of jail okay get
this
so he went to jail for getting in
trouble with the penny stocks thing and
investors and losing the money
he gets out of jail for that waits a few
years and then all of a sudden goes back
with raging bull now i'm gonna give him
credit it was a free product
but it was a tripwire product don't get
it twisted that was so you would buy
more in to the 137 million dollar fraud
he perpetuated it he endorsed it he
should be ashamed of himself
and you guys should remember that the
next time you're thinking of taking
jordan belfort's advice so he's such a
nice guy
the guy is a shark let's be real
speaking of sharks by the way
you know who else is a shark and a bad
one at that
damon john yeah remember the days we
thought
sharks were like you know skeptical
businessmen no they're actually for hire
check this out gales i'm jason bond here
with a man who needs no introduction
remember this is a guy being sued from
the federal trade commission for fraud
whatsoever
damon john from abc shark tank and the
founder of fubu
he started off his life as an educator
and i wanted people to realize that i
can communicate with this person and
they're going to be able to educate me
what was he was he an elementary school
teacher was he a high school teacher
either way how does that qualify him to
teach stocks
damon john seems to think you're a
teacher you're qualified to go do rocket
science later
what the hell is wrong with this guy did
he not vet
jason bond at all step by step on how to
improve my life
as a trader just this year alone over
half a million dollars trading part-time
guys let me remind you persistent and
substantial losses
over half a million dollars trading by
the way bond isn't his last name he
named himself that because you know it
sounds nice
you know stocks and bonds jason bond
anyway this is what the gurus all do
being a school teacher and now
transforming my life
to where i am today that's a powerful
move for me
big career move i went from a school
teacher to being sued by the federal
trade commission
moving up in the world and i'm so happy
that you're showing
uh you know my family all these things
they can do and
one point i'm happy that you showed me
because i'm doing it now as well
guys damon john was paid for this
endorsement
it was not oh out of the kindness of my
heart i just like you
he was paid to do this this is how
social proof works
you think these guys just get endorsed
by these crazy people no they pay for it
in 2020 you can manufacture all the
social proof you want from anybody you
want you can get a kevin o'leary cameo
you can get the titans of trade with
daymond john it's embarrassing
reason why i flew jason out here because
after i realized that i was overlooking
so much opportunity in the market and i
do know stocks very well and i have
excellent excellent financial advisors
yeah i think that's where we're gonna
end it guys credibility of damon john
destroyed credibility of this man i'm
not sure he ever had it
credibility of jeff bishop sustained
substantial and persistent losses
credibility of jordan belfort also down
the tube
it's a bad look but a good lesson good
lesson in the stock traders these
unregistered people
do yourself a favor go get someone who's
qualified to do what they're doing or
learn to do it on your own from free
resources save yourself
tons of money as you can see turns out
it's pretty easy to take people's money
with a slick grin some crazy claims and
a few endorsements
from some friends that's all for now
we'll see you next time and don't forget
to smash like
and subscribe thank you